[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
wiederholt sich Geschichte die Frage
kann man in diesen Zeiten ja in
vielerlei Hinsicht stellen etwa mit
Blick auf Georgien wo Außenministerin
bärburg heute zu Besuch war die
Schicksalsfrage Georgiens erinnert an
die Ukraine 2014 an die Zeit des
euromeidan als ich eine pro-europäische
Bevölkerung gegen die damals
russland-hörige Regierung in Kiew verhub
mit Erfolg doch direkt danach
marschierte Russland auf der Krim ein
Moskau droht nun bereits unverhohlen
dass es den Georgien ähnlicher gehen
könnte
Proteste tief ist vor zweieinhalb Wochen
waren eindrucklich Menschen die mit der
eu-fahne in der Hand bleibt und Leben
riskieren für Demokratie für
Selbstbestimmung für Europa
eine brisante Gemengelage in die die
deutsche Ministerin gereist ist Andreas
Kühnast hat das beobachtet
das weiße bitte ab hier ab dem Dorf
mukrani sind keine zivilen Fahrzeuge
mehr erlaubt keine Ausnahmen für
Minister 20 Minuten noch bis zur
sogenannten verwaltungslinie hinter der
sich gleich der erste russische
Stützpunkt verschanzt da ist eine Wiese
und in der Wiese drin ist der
die Wiese und alles da drüben ist
südostizien nur anerkannt von Russland
Venezuela Nicaragua und Syrien auch da
drüben ist Georgien sagen der Rest der
Welt und Georgien ich danke der
deutschen Delegation dass sie die
territoriale Integrität unseres Landes
so unterstützt
russlandsbesetzung Russlands Einfluss
ist das Thema von bärbox besucht das
Thema Georgiens Herr bittert kämpft das
Land seit Wochen um seine Zukunft auf
der Straße zehntausende die den Weg in
Richtung EU fortsetzen wollen im
Parlament die Regierung die sich mit
Händen und Fäusten gegen die dafür
nötigen Reformen Wert ein sogenanntes
agentengesetz wie in Russland hätte das
Staatsziel EU beinahe zerstört Georgien
gehört zur du die Menschen die orgiens
sie gehören in die EU vertrauen Sie
nicht dieser Regierung das ist die
Botschaft die diese mitorganisatorinnen
der Proteste bärbock mitgeben auf allzu
scharfe Kritik an Georgiens Regierung
hat bärburg verzichtet weil sie keine
grundsätzlichen Zweifel an ihrem eu-kurs
hat auch wenn das die Opposition hier in
tief ist völlig anders einschätzt
Deutschland sieht wie Georgien schwankt
und sicher dem Land Stabilisierung zu
und der georgische Wissenschaftler und
Publizist Saal andronikash willi ist uns
zugeschaltet Essen tiefes geboren hatte
in Deutschland Literaturwissenschaft in
Deutschland und in Georgien
Literaturwissenschaften und Geschichte
studiert und arbeitet am leibnizzentrum
für Literatur und Kulturforschung in
Berlin guten Abend nach Berlin guten
Abend Frau Slomka Frau Berber hat ja
heute sinngemäß gesagt wir die EU
reichen Ihnen die Hand aber man ist sich
eigentlich nicht so sicher ob die
aktuelle georgische Regierung diese Hand
überhaupt haben will oder ob sie nicht
längst im festen Griffen und Bild zu
bleiben moskauz hängt das ist sehr
bedauerlich dass die georgische
Regierung sich nicht klar in dieser
Sache positioniert sie driftet immer
mehr Richtung Russland aber die Menschen
in Georgien Georgien und Georgien
erinnern wollen auf jeden Fall in ihren
das haben sie in den vergangenen Wochen
gezeigt indem Sie auf die Straße
gegangen sind und für die europäische
Zukunft Georgiens protestiert haben ja
diese Proteste die sehr eindrücklich und
wenn man Umfragen verfolgt sind über 80
Prozent der georgischen Bürger ja auch
für die einen Beitritt zur EU das
erinnert so ein bisschen an die Ukraine
2014 als es da auch zum Schwur kam wenn
sie auf der einen Seite eine Russland
nahe Regierung auf der anderen Seite
eine in die EU nach Europa wollende
Bevölkerung das ist ein Teil des selben
Prozesses die Befreiung der ehemaligen
sowjetischen Ländern aus ihrer
sowjetischen Vergangenheit und die
Menschen in der Ukraine und die Menschen
in Georgien aber auch in Moldau zeigen
dass sie sich für die europäische
Zukunft entschieden haben das Problem
dabei ist dass die Regierungen Eliten
Oligarchen und natürlich Russland diesem
Willen der Menschen sich wiedersetzen
weil sie in den intransparenten
Verhältnissen oder in den autokratischen
Regimen mehr
Vorteile für sich verschaffen die die
georgische Regierungspartei ist ja auch
von einem der reichsten Männer oder dem
reichsten Mann Georgiens gegründet
worden das ist wahr wie Sinai war nicht
viele ist so ein Georgia aber ist
genauso ein russischer Oligarchen dem
Sinne dass er sein Geld in Russland
verdient hat oder gemacht hat je nachdem
wie man es sagen möchte und für ihn sind
dann die russischen Verhältnisse die in
transparenten wirtschaftlichen
Verhältnisse die intransparenten
politischen Verhältnisse natürliches
Milieu das ist daher kein Wunder dass er
auch in Georgien ein Regime aufbaut das
alles andere als demokratisch ist also
würden Sie sagen dass demokratierechte
die sehr an Georgien durchaus gibt dass
die auch zunehmend abgebaut wurden in
letzter Zeit sie wurde seit 2012 seitdem
georgischer Traum an der Macht ist
konsequent abgebaut es gab auch früher
Rückschläge in der Demokratie aber es
gab keine Rückschläge in dem westlichen
oder europäischen Kurs Georgiens das ist
aber ein Novum das ist eine schwierige
Regimes und des georgischen Traums dann
haben wir auch durch den ukrainekrieg
durch den Krieg Russlands gegen die
Ukraine erlebt dass viele viele Russen
nach Georgien sich geflüchtet haben die
nicht zum Militär eingezogen werden
wollten zum Beispiel welche Rolle
spielen die jetzt im Blick auf die
gesamt Zusammensetzung der ja doch
überschaubaren georgischen Bevölkerung
es gibt sehr viele Sorgen dass eben auch
diese russische Bevölkerung von Russland
instrumentalisiert werden könnte wolle
Russland jetzt zum Beispiel Georgien
angreifen aber im Moment verhalten sich
sehr viele Russen unauffällig es in der
nächsten Zeit nach Demonstrationen
gingen auch sehr viele nach Russland
zurück insbesondere danach als die
chef-propagandistin
Russlands Zimmer Geister Simon Jan auf
Bomben mit beliebige tot hat ja die
droht ja auch mit Bomben auf dem
Bundestag und überhaupt überall hin die
die Propagandisten also den
Propagandamaschinerie Russlands läuft eh
aber die Frage ist natürlich wie
gefährlich diese ja auch schon aus
Moskau zu hörenden Drohungen waren dass
man eventuell Georgien auch angreifen
werde zwei Provinzen hat man ja schon
unter Kontrolle zwei georgische
Provinzen hat Russland besetzt der
Preise in und Südosten und
weder Georgien nach Moldawien ist Dr
Moldau ist sicher von der russischen
Angriffe im Moment die ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit eher gering ähm aber
die Gefahr besteht trotzdem und es ist
deswegen wichtig dass Länder wie
Georgien Ukraine und Moldau schnell in
die oder so schnell wie möglich in die
EU aufgenommen werden damit sie
zumindest in einen anderen
Sicherheitsraum auch kommen unter
anderem die Stimme eines Georgiers an
diesem Abend soll an Monika schwierig
danke sehr für das Gespräch danke
das Interview haben wir aufgezeichnet
das kleine Georgien mit den bereits
russisch kontrollierten Gebieten wäre
für Russland wo leichter zu unterwerfen
als die Ukraine ob das jetzt im Moment
noch gilt steht auf einem anderen Blatt
schwer zu sagen welche Kräfte die
russische Armee noch hat und ob sie
aktuell einen zweiten Krieg leisten
könnte in der Ukraine bleiben die
durchschlagenden Erfolge jedenfalls
weiter aus bestenfalls gibt es einen
langsames qualvolles Vorankommen an
diesen und jenem Frontabschnitt unsere
Reporterin an den Brüder ist nach
kopians gefahren die Stadt im Nordosten
der Ukraine war im September von der
ukrainischen Armee befreit worden doch
die Russen sind zuletzt wieder näher
heran gerückt und die Stadt liegt unter
Dauer Beschuss
normale Geschäfte gibt es in Coupons
schon lange nicht mehr auf der Straße
verkauft ein Bauer Milch wir treffen
Tatjana sie ist 14 Jahre alt
schwer aber wir halten durch
hast du Angst hier sind ständig die
Explosionen zu hören
ich habe mich daran gewöhnt
leben in ständiger Gefahr und doch geht
der Alltag weiter der Bankautomat
funktioniert ausnahmsweise deshalb hat
sich davor eine Schlange gebildet
wir haben uns schon daran gewöhnt es ist
uns egal einfach normal
man kann damit leben wir sind hier zu
Hause und zu Hause ist es immer gut
dabei ist nichts gut in Kopien knapp
30.000 Einwohner hatte die Stadt in der
Nähe der russischen Grenze mal jetzt
sind die meisten geflohen geblieben sind
vor allem die älteren
wohin soll ich fahren wer braucht mich
mit so einer niedrigen Rente
2500 riffner wo kann ich für dieses Geld
leben eine Wohnung kann ich nirgendwo
mieten und die Hunde kann ich nicht
zurücklassen
wir denken dass wir siegen werden wir
haben nicht vor unsere Stadt zu
verlassen die russischen Stellungen sind
nur ein paar Kilometer entfernt trotzdem
gehen die Menschen auf den Markt
verkaufen das Wenige was ihnen geblieben
ist
die Stadt ist voller Soldaten sie decken
sich auf dem Markt mit Tarnkleidung ein
dass die Front wieder so nah ist
kommentieren Sie lapidar
normal alles normal
die Behörden bereiten die Evakuierung
vor es gibt Notfallpläne aber im Bus
nach hakif sind viele Plätze frei noch
wird keiner zur Umsiedlung gezwungen
kurz gesagt es ist gefährlich alle die
hier bleiben wissen dass sie am Morgen
vielleicht nicht aufwachen werden wenn
die Situation sich verschlechtert dann
kommt natürlich die Evakuierung es gibt
Telefonnummern alle wissen alles man ist
informiert so ist das
Leben von Tag zu Tag anders geht es
gerade nicht den Kopien
es macht erstmal Heinz Wolff weiter
zunächst mit Nachrichten aus Deutschland
das am Montag wohl ziemlich stilllegen
wird der große waren streikt Tag im
öffentlichen Verkehr sorgt für heftige
Diskussionen werde Schiff Wernicke
räumte ein der Tag werde für große Teile
der Bevölkerung eine Belastung
darstellen aber besser sei ein Tag mit
Belastung dann allerdings mit der
Perspektive zu einem Tarifabschluss zu
kommen als ein wochenlanger Arbeitskampf
die Bundesregierung verwies darauf dass
der Streikrecht ein Grundrecht sei
grundsätzlich rufe man aber dazu auf
dass die Tarifpartner bald zu einer
tragfähigen Lösung finden
Bundeskanzler Scholz rechnet im Streit
mit der EU-Kommission über die Zukunft
von Neuwagen mit Verbrennungsmotoren mit
einer schnellen Einigung ziemlich zügig
werde das passieren sagte Scholz nach
dem EU-Gipfel in Brüssel
kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
betonte das Vorhaben sei eine wichtige
Säule um die EU-Klimaziele zu erreichen
nach einer Grundsatzeinigung sollen ab
2035 nur noch emissionsfrei Neuwagen
zugelassen werden dürfen deutschland
drängt darauf auch danach Neuwagen mit
Verbrenner zuzulassen die ausschließlich
efuse also emissionsfreie Kraftstoffe
tanken
bundesinnenministerin Faser fordert eine
schnelle Einigung über eine Reform des
europäischen Asylsystems wenn die Reform
bis zum Sommer nicht komme und damit
auch keine verlässliche Registrierung an
den EU-Außengrenzen sei der Schengen
Raum mit offenen Binnengrenzen in großer
gefahren sagte Fräser bei einem Treffen
mit mehreren EU Amtskollegen uneinigkeit
herrscht unter den EU-Ländern unter
anderem bei dem von Deutschland
geforderten solidaritätsmechanismus der
Länder an der EU Außengrenze entlasten
soll
die Streiks und teils gewaltsamen
Proteste in Frankreich haben jetzt dazu
geführt dass der ab Sonntag geplante
besuchte es britischen Königs Charles
des dritten abgesagt wurde das
bestätigte Präsident macron am Rande des
EU-Gipfels in Brüssel für kommenden
Dienstag haben die Gewerkschaften zu
neuen landesweiten Streiks und Protesten
gegen die Rentenreform aufgerufen
im Osten Spaniens kämpfen hunderte
Feuerwehrleute gegen den ersten großen
Waldbrand des Jahres und das deutlich
vor der eigentlichen Waldbrand Saison
das Feuer war gestern etwa 90 km
nördlich der Stadt Valencia ausgebrochen
eine Fläche von fast 4000 Hektar ist
betroffen nach offiziellen Angaben
wurden bislang etwa 1500 Menschen in
Sicherheit gebracht mit Hilfe von
Löschflugzeugen und Helikoptern versucht
die Feuerwehr den Brand unter Kontrolle
zu bringen
Altena im Juli 2021 eine der Gemeinden
die bei der Flutkatastrophe in Aartal
schwerst zerstört wurden die Spuren sind
bis heute zu sehen die Trauer um die
Toten bleibt und auch die
Fassungslosigkeit darüber wie
unvorbereitet der Katastrophenschutz
viele Orts war obwohl es
Hochwasserwarnungen gegeben hatte das
ist bis heute nicht vollständig
aufgearbeitet an welchen Stellen
versagte das Krisenmanagement in der
Flucht
zu denen die sich da weiterhin
drängenden Fragen stellen müssen gehört
die rheinland-pfälzische
Ministerpräsidentin Dreier die heute
erneut vor den Untersuchungsausschuss
des Landtags geladen war Christian
Malu Dreyer ahnte wohl dass es lange
dauern würde drei Stunden lang wird sie
im uhrausschuss befragt sie wirkt
angespannt sie ist zum zweiten Mal
geladen wieder geht es um die flutnacht
und darum was sie wann von den
Ereignissen wusste sie bleibt bei ihren
Aussagen von damals
ich hatte keinerlei Kenntnis dafür dass
zum Teil örtliche Behörden nicht
funktioniert haben und auch nicht davon
dass die Flutkatastrophe ein solches
Ausmaß hat
das Ausmaß sah so aus
unvorstellbare Wassermassen die in den
kleinen Orten entlang der er wüten und
alles mit sich Wissen Heimat die keine
mehr ist allein im Ahrtal sterben 134
Menschen und über allem die Frage warum
wurde die Lage falsch eingeschätzt
der damalige Innenminister Lebens ist
noch am flutabend in der Technischen
Einsatzleitung in Ahrweiler für eine
halbe Stunde alle hätten konzentriert
gearbeitet um kurz vor 1 schreibt er an
die Ministerpräsidentin Liebe marlu die
Lage eskaliert es kann Tote geben
gegeben haben erst um 5:33 Uhr
antwortete Dreier lieber Roger ich bin
erreichbar dazwischen keine
Kommunikation dabei hatte noch am späten
Abend ein Polizeihubschrauber dieses
Video gedreht Häuser bis zum Dach im
Wasser um Hilfe pflegende Bewohner
Aufnahmen die 14 Monate verschwunden
waren und plötzlich wieder auftauchten
der Innenminister ein enger Vertrauter
der Ministerpräsidentin musste
zurücktreten
jetzt steht Malu Dreyer vor dem
U-Ausschuss im Fokus die Opposition
sieht die Gesamtverantwortung für das
Katastrophenmanagement bei ihr
wir sind schon ein Stück weit beschämt
vom Auftritt der Ministerpräsidentin sie
trägt die Verantwortung dafür für das
Handeln der Landesregierung und dann ist
es auch Zeit dass sie sich über ihre
eigenen persönlichen Konsequenzen
Gedanken macht
Dreier bleibt bei ihrer Haltung nichts
falsch gemacht zu haben sie sah am Tag
nach der Flut aktiv geworden und schnell
vor Ort gewesen und ich kann noch einmal
nur betonen
die Menschen die heute noch an den
Folgen dieser Flut leiten das ist mir
sehr sehr leid tut und ich auch oft in
Gedanken bei ihnen sind die
Flutkatastrophe und die Rolle der
Ministerpräsidentin Malu Dreyer hat sich
zumindest heute nicht in Bedrängnis
bringen lassen der
Untersuchungsausschuss Takt weiter und
die Opposition wird nicht locker lassen
die EU berät seit dieser Woche über ein
Verbot sogenannter
ewigkeits-chemikalien der Begriff von
sich war heißt ja schon nichts Gutes
Chemikalien die wenn Sie einmal in die
Umwelt eingedrungen sind dort sehr sehr
lange bleiben durchaus 1000 Jahre lang
die Abkürzung PVS ist der Fachbegriff
für diese chemikaliengruppe Stoffe die
man nicht riecht schmeckt oder spürt die
über höchst gesundheitsgefährdend sein
können wenn sie falsch entsorgt werden
oder bei der Herstellung in die Umwelt
gelangen etwas Grundwasser
Beläge ein Verbot doch nahe aber die
Sache ist kompliziert und befasst sind
fast überall die Oliver Heuchert
was hat der Löschschaum zur
Feuerbekämpfung mit Outdoor und
Arbeitsbekleidung gemeinsam oder mit
beschichteten Pfannen oder mit Papier in
das Fast Food eingeschlagen wird oder
mit Mobiltelefonen oder mit Zahnseide
es ist PVS was in diesen und noch viel
mehr Produkten verwendet wird PVS steht
für Poly und per Flur alcylsubstanzen
sie sind so stabil dass sie auch als
Ewigkeit Chemikalien bezeichnet werden
rund 10.000 verschiedene industriell
hergestellte Stoffe die vor allem
auszeichnet dass sie Wasser und
fettabstoßen schmutzabweisend
eingefärbtes Wasser und oben drüber
haben wir Ölen also quasi eine Salatsoße
mit drei Phasen und das zeigt auch dass
diese andere mischbar sind aber das
jetzt schüttelt sieht man die entmischen
sich sehr schnell wieder zudem sind sie
sehr stabil das heißt sie gehen unter
Extrembedingungen nicht kaputt also es
kann sie auch bei extremer Hitze hohen
Druck oder Strahlung oder ein Gegenwart
aggressiver andere Chemikalien einsetzen
ohne dass sie ihre Eigenschaften
verlieren
Anfang 2005 rutschte auf dem
Düsseldorfer Flughafen eine
Frachtmaschine über die Landebahn hinaus
und fängt Feuer der eingesetzte
Löschschaum gelangt in die Umgebung bis
heute ist die Wassernutzung in Teilen
Düsseldorfs deswegen eingeschränkt
auch das Umfeld des Militärflughafens
sprang Dahlem in Rheinland-Pfalz ist
durch Löcher und belastet was alle
Flughäfen sind PVS belastet wie auch die
Bereiche rund um Fabriken die PVS
herstellen
an der Möhnetalsperre bei Arnsberg
musste das Wasser jahrelang in solchen
aktivkohlebecken gefiltert werden Fische
aus diesem Gewässer sollen nach wie vor
nur selten verzehrt werden
hier wurde pefashaltiger Schlamm als
Dünger ausgebracht also man findet
papers quasi überall in uns um uns unter
anderem weil sie in vielen Produkten
verwendet werden die wir auch
konsumieren aber auch die wir tragen
Outdoorbekleidung Wanderbekleidung zum
Beispiel
studienweisen darauf hin dass PVS im
menschlichen Körper unter anderem dazu
führen kann dass Impfungen weniger
wirksam sind dass das Risiko für Nieren
und Hodenkrebs steigt dass die
Fruchtbarkeit abnimmt dass die
Blutfettwerte steigen die für die Umwelt
größte Besorgnis die wir sehen ist eben
die Langlebigkeit dieser Substanzen das
heißt wenn Sie einmal in die Umwelt
gelangt sind gehen Sie davon selbst
nicht mehr weg sie sind unter
natürlichen Bedingungen nicht abbaubar
wir nehmen den fast zum meist über die
Nahrung auf Wildfleisch und Innereien
werden hier besonders genannt oder
Fische oder Trinkwasser aus belasteten
Gewässern der Gebrauch von Peters
beschichteten Produkten im Alltag gilt
als weitgehend unproblematisch
[Musik]
vor der EU Chemikalien Agentur ECHA in
Helsinki läuft jetzt das
beschränkungsverfahren manche Arten von
pefas sind bereits verboten und werden
mittlerweile auch seltener in der Umwelt
gefunden jetzt geht es um die gesamte
Produktgruppe
und jetzt geht's mit dem Blick auf die
Finanzmärkte diese Woche ja zum Schluss
dieser Handelswoche ist der Dax wieder
knapp unter die 15.000 Punkte gerutscht
eines der Top-Themen auch heute die
Situation am Bankenmarkt Frank Mettmann
was hat sich da heute getan ja die
Sorgen sind zurück die sorgen dass nach
der Notrettung der Schweizer
großbank-kredit Suisse am vergangenen
Wochenende weitere Geldhäuser ins
Straucheln geraten könnten trotz
vielfacher Beschwichtigungen Schwapp die
Vertrauenskrise heute über auf den
heimischen Bankensektor unter Druck vor
allem die Deutsche Bank der Kanzler
versucht vom EU-Gipfel aus so beruhigen
die Deutsche Bank hat dir Geschäftskunde
grundlegende
modernisiert und neu organisiert und ist
eine sehr profitable Bank doch es hilft
wenig nach vorübergehend bis zu 15
Prozent Abschlag verliert die Aktie am
Ende achteinhalb Prozent ohne das ist
dazu neue schlechte Nachrichten gab und
doch steigen wir aus dem Nichts die
Preise für Kreditausfallversicherung der
Deutschen Bank enorm ein Alarmsignal
denn wer sich nun absichern will gegen
einen möglichen Zahlungsausfall der
Deutschen Bank der muss dafür sprunghaft
gestiegene Preise hinnehmen
Erklärungsversuch eines marktbeobachters
im Gespräch mit dem Handelsblatt wir
sind noch immer nervös ob ein weiterer
Dominostein fällt und die Deutsche Bank
ist ganz klar die nächste an die jeder
denkt egal ob das gerechtfertigt ist
oder nicht mit Blick auf den heutigen
Tag macht es gerade er den Eindruck eine
Krise wird dabei geredet als dass sie
auf wirklichen Fakten beruht Frank
Bethmann vielen Dank
zum Abschluss des Skisprung Weltcups im
finnischen lacht die hat
Rekordweltmeisterin Katharina Althaus
ihren achten Sieg des Winters knapp
verpasst nach der Führung zur Halbzeit
erreichte die obersdorferin nach einem
schwächeren zweiten Versuch am Ende den
dritten Platz der sieging an Yukito aus
Japan Platz 2 an die Norwegerinnen an
der odiniströhm
18 Sportarten 129 deutsche Meistertitel
das sind die Finals 2023 vom 6 bis 9
juli
Austragungsorte diesmal Duisburg
Düsseldorf Kassel und Berlin ZDF und ARD
sind wieder live dabei
umfangreiche Berichterstattung im
Fernsehen und in verschiedenen
Livestreams die Finals 2023 ein
Multisport Event im Sommer das in diesem
Jahr schwerpunktmäßig in der Region
Rhein-Ruhr stattfindet wir holen den
Sport hier ganz nah an die an die
Menschen ran ein bisschen eine Mischung
aus Sportfest und Volksfest die
Zuschauer vor Ort werden sowohl
traditionelle Sportarten wie Triathlon
und turnen als auch junge olympische
Sportarten wie breaking und Klettern zu
Gesicht bekommen noch rund 100 Tage bis
sich Deutschlands beste Athletinnen und
Athleten miteinander messen werden
das Fußballtrainer gefeuert werden
manchmal auch schon nach ziemlich kurze
Amtszeit ist jetzt an sich ja keine
Seltenheit gehört zum jobrisiko dazu
aber wenn es beim FC Bayern solche
Trainer Dramen gibt dann schauen alle
hin wir auch und Michael Krämer
berichtet
632 Tage war Julian nagelsmann Trainer
des FC Bayern es ist das yeah Ende eines
Projekts das ursprünglich auf mindestens
fünf Jahre ausgelegt war nach einem
Treffen an derselbener Straße heute
folgte von Vereins Seite am frühen Abend
die Bestätigung dessen was bereits
gestern urplötzlich durchsickerte nach
der WM haben wir immer weniger
erfolgreich und attraktiv gespielt die
starken Leistungsschwankungen haben
unsere Ziele in dieser Saison in Frage
gestellt aber auch über diese Saison
hinaus deshalb haben wir jetzt reagiert
Bayerns Wunschkandidat im Sommer 2021
für eine horende Ablöse Summe vom Liga
Konkurrenten RB Leipzig an die Isar
gelockt und mit einem langen Vertrag bis
Juni 2026 ausgestattet ein Umstand der
nagelsmann bei seiner damaligen
Vorstellung noch Scherzen ließ
ich glaube für ein Jahr wäre ich auch
nicht gekommen
der 35-Jährige sollte eine Ehre beim FC
Bayern prägen doch in seiner ersten
Saison zunächst das planable Aus in der
zweiten Runde des DFB-Pokals und dann
auch noch das Champions League
Halbfinale verpasst nur die
Meisterschale zu wenig für das
Selbstverständnis des FCB in der
aktuellen Spielzeit wären für nagelsmann
noch alle Titel möglich gewesen Paris im
Achtelfinale der Königsklasse souverän
bezwungen doch die Mannschaft noch immer
zu in Konstanz die Tabellenführung nach
der Niederlage gegen Leverkusen
vergangenen Sonntag abgegeben für die
Führungsriege um Oliver Kahn grund genug
die Reißleine zu ziehen für viele
unerwartet
also wir waren natürlich gestern Abend
auch sehr sehr überrascht über die
Schlagzeilen was ich sagen kann ist das
äh
Julian möglichen ja überragender Trainer
ist eine der besten die ich je hatte für
nagelsmann wird nun eine Abfindungen
Millionenhöhe fällig Thomas Tuchel
Champions League Sieger mit Chelsea sein
Nachfolger zwei Jahre lang stand er an
der Seitenlinie beim BVB gegen den er
nun sein erstes Spiel als Bayern Trainer
bestreiten wird der Fußball bleibt ein
schnelllebiges unvorhersehbares Geschäft
ja und die Bayern Spieler sind derzeit
ja im Trainingslager für das Länderspiel
morgen abend Deutschland gegen Peru und
da werden wir uns in der Halbzeitpause
melden gegen 21 Uhr
hier geht es jetzt gleich erstmal weiter
mit der heute show oder 20 gibt es dann
unsere heute schon mal Update mit einer
mir auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
ja guten Abend das war eine sehr
geschäftige Woche für uns
meteorologinnen und Meteorologen erstens
der Welttag der Metrologie und zweitens
hat der Weltklimarat ja wieder
eindringlicher denn je auf mehr
Klimaschutz gedrängt geschäftlich geht
es auch jetzt beim aktuellen Wetter zu
das sehen wir schon an den großen
Temperaturunterschieden in Europa im
Moment morgen erreichen wir Höchstwerte
von -10 Grad im Norden Skandinaviens auf
der iberischen Halbinsel sind das
dagegen um 30 Grad ja und bei uns kommen
jetzt in der nächsten Zeit diese kalte
Nord Luft an hier ein Beispiel von
Berlin sinken die Temperaturen über das
Wochenende von 15 auf nur noch 5 Grad in
der Nacht auf Dienstag ist frostmöglich
und es gibt die Option auf Schnee das
ist aber heute Nacht noch nicht der Fall
da gibt es Schauer auch mal einzelne
Gewitter es ist stark bewölkt die Nacht
ist mit vier bis acht Grad noch recht
mild aber nicht so mild wie die
vergangene da hatten wir Tiefstwerte von
12 Grad morgen haben wir weiterhin auf
zweistellige Werte nur an der Nordsee
und im Bergland ist es etwas weniger ja
und dazu gibt es einen Tag an dem es
überall mal alles geben kann grauen
Himmel Schauer dann Auflockerungen auch
einzelne Gewitter können entstehen und
es wird sich sehr rau anfühlen denn wir
haben einen frischen bis starken
südwestlichen Wind und da sind
verbreitet stürmische Böden möglich in
diesem gelben Flächen hier in Gewittern
auch Sturmböen in Berglagen sind schwere
Sturmböen drin und dieser ungestüme Wind
der weht dann die Frühlingsluft davon am
Montag wie gesagt nur noch Höchstwerte
zwischen zwei und acht Grad der kräftige
Nordwind wird auch in die Schneeflocken
wieder zurückbringen am Sonntag noch
vergleichsweise mild mit viel Regen in
der Mitte und im Süden im Norden bleibt
es dagegen trocken tschüss